okay it looks like we're live
all right welcome to week three and day
five
of distributed systems if you've stuck
with us this far
congratulations you're 20
done with the course it's pretty amazing
all right
so today uh we have a lot to get through
and i'm actually not sure if we're going
to get through it all because
even though this is material that i've
taught before i'm going to try to teach
it in a slightly different way than i've
done before
so this is a bit of an experiment and
we'll see how we do
so i'm going to put this you know pretty
ambitious agenda up
and uh we'll just see if we manage to
get through it all
so first we're going to recap the
delivery properties that we talked about
last time
and if you recall last time we talked
about how to implement
fifo delivery but we didn't talk about
how to implement the other delivery
properties that we talked about which
were
causal delivery and totally ordered
delivery so
we're going to talk about implementing a
particular kind of causal delivery
which is called causal broadcast
and this word causal here should be a
big hint that this is going to involve
vector clocks
then we're going to zoom out and look at
uses
of causality
in distributed systems and then we're
going to look at
a different application for causality
which is called the jandy lam port
snapshot algorithm
so this is ambitious let's see if we
have enough time to get through all of
it
by the way uh so i know that different
people like to ask questions in class in
different ways i know that some people
like to type things in and if that's you
then you know you can go ahead and type
things in
uh in zoom chat or sorry not in zoom
chat please don't use zoom chat but in
in zulu chat if you
are uncomfortable typing something into
into zulip
uh you can always uh like in in the
public chat then you can always
send me a private message on zulip and
you can also just ask questions out loud
so i noticed that not too many people
are doing that
but you can if you want to and sometimes
that's a good way to communicate like if
i ask you a question
it can be a lot faster to just say
something than to type
so please feel free to to communicate by
voice if you want to
i would say no you don't have to raise
your hand because somebody just asked on
chat do you have to raise your hand i
would say no
for two reasons one um i don't think
that many people are going to be
speaking out loud so i don't think it's
going to be a huge issue
and if there's a little bit of overlap
i'm not too worried and then the other
reason is
just to tell you the truth i don't have
time always to look at who's raising
their hand
so um
let's just try um you know speaking out
loud if you want to
and if it goes poorly today we can
always adapt
all right so let's jump right in we're
going to recap the delivery properties
that we talked about last time
so
i'll start a new page for this because i
think we're going to need a lot of room
so we talked about three different
properties
and so one of them was if you recall
from last time one of them was called
fifo delivery or first in first out
delivery
and here's a picture of a violation
of fifo delivery
and recall from before
that when you're talking about these
kinds of properties sometimes it's
easier to draw a picture of what's not
supposed to happen
so it's easier to sum up uh
uh violations or it's easier to sum up
what fifo delivery means
by drawing a picture of what it means to
violate fifo delivery
that's easier than drawing it drawing
pictures of all the infinitely many
executions that do respect fifo delivery
so there's a question which is should
you feel free to unmute to ask questions
yes feel free to unmute to ask questions
or answer a question
so that's a violation of fifo delivery
we also talked about causal delivery so
here's a picture
of our classic violation of causal
delivery
and finally we talked about totally
ordered delivery so here's that
so in each case it's a little bit easier
to talk about them by drawing a picture
of what doesn't happen
under each of these uh delivery
properties okay so
yeah go ahead
yeah that's right so um the question was
are there protocols that we can use
to ensure that these violations don't
happen and the answer is absolutely yes
so last time we talked about
ways to make sure that you have fifo
delivery in other words ways to prevent
this sort of violation
and this time we're going to talk about
how to prevent violations of causal
delivery
under certain circumstances um
preventing violations of totally ordered
delivery is actually a bigger topic so
we'll get to that a little bit later in
the course
okay so somebody asked a really good
question
last time uh in uh in chat
uh which was about it was something like
oh is fifo delivery is subset of causal
delivery
um so it actually looks like this
so these are properties of executions
remember that a lan port diagram is a is
a
illustration of an execution of a
distributed system
so when we talk about like observing
fifo delivery or observing causal
delivery
the thing that observes that property is
an execution
so one way to talk about this is to draw
a big picture
where i've got this big circle here and
this is
all executions
so absolutely anything could happen uh
in an execution that's in this circle
you could have
fifo delivery be violated for example
you could have totally ordered delivery
be violated um anything could happen so
i'll put
yolo here
anything can happen within that
a subset of those
are going to be executions that observe
fifo delivery
and within that
there's going to be a subset of that
which are the executions that observe
causal delivery
so if it's an execution that observes
if it's in this circle here notice that
it's also going to observe fifo delivery
but if it observes fifo delivery it
doesn't necessarily
observe causal so that's the
relationship between those two
um so here's a question for you
where do you think that totally ordered
delivery would go in this picture
any ideas
ah just a second
how's that
yeah i don't know what happened zoom
just hiccup okay it should be fine now
uh okay so where do you think
the circle would go for executions that
observe totally ordered delivery any
thoughts on that
the answer is a little bit weird so one
person says
should it be in here inside execution's
observing causal delivery
somebody else says would it go in in the
yolo bubble
somebody else says inside the fifo
delivery bubble so yeah so
you're actually all right in a sense
because
execution's observing totally ordered
delivery would go
like this
so this is a little bit weird right we
don't have this
uh total hierarchy of um
of executions instead you could have an
execution that
observes totally ordered delivery but
doesn't observe fifo
uh on the other hand you could have an
execution that observes totally ordered
delivery
and observes by fifo but not causal or
you could have one that observes totally
ordered delivery
and causal and fifo so there's like the
zone in here
which i'll highlight in green
and this would be
to put a little legend on this picture
here
this one would be executions
with both
totally ordered and causal
delivery
and on the other hand uh you could have
some executions that are in this zone
out here
and let's do different kind of hash
marks here
because i know that not everybody can
see the difference between the
the colors
so these would be executions that are
that are totally ordered but
not fifo so that's kind of
interesting right so what would be an
example of an execution
that is totally ordered but not fifo
so let's look at a picture of an
execution that would fall into that
red zone
so it could be something like this maybe
you've got
three processes
and process one here sends
messages and let's say it sends messages
to process two in process three so let's
say it does like this
and then later it also sends messages
to process two and process three and
those go like this
so do you see what's going on here so
the way that i did it was
process one sent
these two messages we could call them m1
and m2 the order at which they arrived
at process two here
was flipped around so process two got
message two and then message one
and process three also got m2 and then
m1
so in some sense uh process two got the
messages in the wrong order
so that's a violation of fifo clearly
but then so did process three it also
got the messages in the wrong order so
the messages arrived and were delivered
in the wrong order but consistently the
same
at every process so that
observes totally ordered delivery
totally ordered delivery says
that if a particular process delivers
messages in a certain order then so does
everybody else who delivers those
messages
so this would be an execution that falls
into this funny-looking red zone
here and so this is just to show you
that uh that there's not a total
hierarchy
of of these kinds of delivery guarantees
so you can have executions that observe
totally ordered delivery but don't
uh observe causal or even fifo delivery
and when we look at totally ordered
delivery
uh one thing that we're going to be
thinking about is
uh do we also
guarantee causal delivery with our with
our algorithms for ensuring total order
delivery that'll come later in the
course
so because that's not necessarily get
something that you get for free when you
implement totally ordered delivery
that's something that you would have to
give extra thought to
unlike with causal if we're implementing
a causal delivery mechanism
you get fifo delivery for free as you
can see from the way that these
these circles are nested not so with
totally ordered delivery
so that's a quick recap of of the
delivery guarantees or the the
guarantees
uh the um the properties of executions
that we talked about last time
any questions on that before we move on
is sending different from delivering
uh was the question yeah so recall how
we talked about so what delivery means
is let's say that you
uh get a message
and um
[Music]
we've talked about what sending and and
and receiving
i mean um so you know if p1 sends a
message and p2 receives it
um so p1 chooses when to send the
message they can choose whether and when
to send the message
p2 doesn't have any choice in the matter
of whether they uh
whether they receive the message or not
that receiving is just something that
happens to you
but here's the way to think about
delivery think about it as there being a
little
male clerk that's hanging out
here um on this
process who is deciding for every
message received
uh deciding should i deliver
this message to its intended recipient
or not so
all incoming messages go into the mail
room
and the mail clerk's job is to choose to
deliver them
to the addressee or not
so um you as a process get you don't get
to choose if you receive messages just
like you don't get to choose if you
receive mail
uh but you get to choose uh whether to
deliver that message so delivery is
something that happens on the receiver's
end
with a received message uh
choosing uh whether or not to to take
that message and
apply it so the way that we have been
drawing that on our lan port diagrams is
by putting a check mark
when we say a message has been delivered
so yes sending and delivering are very
different sending is something that the
sender does
delivery is something that the receiver
may do with a received message
okay so let's move on from there
and the next thing that's on our agenda
is implementing causal broadcast
so this is the first time that i have
used this word
broadcast i think uh so let's take a
moment
to to talk about what that means
so far when we've been talking about
messages being sent and received
uh we've mostly meant that
there's one sender and one receiver
so there's a name for messages like
that and they're called unicast messages
sometimes also called point to point
one sender
one receiver
however i have been cheating a little
because in some of the
lan port diagrams that i've drawn we've
had a situation where there's
one sender and multiple receivers
so that's called multicast
and then a special case of multicast
is broadcast
where one sends
and everyone receives
so as many processes as there are in the
system everybody gets a broadcast
message
so we saw that already in fact when we
talked about
uh violations of causal delivery so in
our classic picture
uh when alice sends her uh
bob smells message
and bob responds
notice that this message from alice
actually has two recipients
so we only think of it as one message
we call this message m1 even though it's
m1 is both of these arrows here
so this is a single message but it's a
broadcast message because it's it's
being sent to everybody likewise this
one is also a broadcast message
and we can call this one m2 so
it turns out that if you were in a
setting where all of your messages are
broadcast messages
that makes it relatively straightforward
to ensure causal delivery so the
algorithm that we're going to look at
today
for ensuring causal delivery is an
algorithm that only works
in the setting where all messages are
broadcast messages
by the way i said here everyone receives
so is there anything being left out of
this picture up here when i said that
everyone receives the messages
what do you think
great yeah so the um the answer is that
the sender ought to be included in
everyone
or at least in many broadcast algorithms
the sender is included
so if we were going to be really
pedantic about it um
then we could draw a little arrow here
that shows alice uh
sending the message to herself as well
and then bob sending the message to
himself
um most of the time we don't put those
little
self arrows in the picture just because
it complicates the picture too much
uh but in general when we talk about
broadcast we mean sending to everybody
including yourself
that could vary depending on on the
setting and
who's talking about it but but that's
generally what we mean
so just to contrast uh broadcast with
multicast
this other picture that we looked at a
second ago uh that was a violation of
totally ordered delivery
um this one happens to be multicast and
not broadcast right because
we've got messages here that are being
sent
to multiple participants but not all of
the participants
so this would be an example of multicast
where you have a message that has more
than one recipient
somebody just asked in chat is there
something for multiple
senders and a single receiver well
i i mean i don't think so right like i
mean you could have
um something like this
where processes zero and one are both
sending to process two
but that i think that would just be
considered two point to point messages
so
i don't i don't have a special name for
that
you could maybe give a special name to
some kind of bigger
communication pattern where you have you
know
maybe one message going out from one
process to everybody and then everybody
acknowledging that one
uh but that would be um
that would be more specific so no i
don't think there's a word in particular
for this kind of thing
um yeah i don't know like
maybe you would call it gather or
something like that
i don't know uh anyway
let's talk about broadcast so we want to
figure out how we can implement an
algorithm that will prevent
this sort of anomaly from happening
and recall that the the bad thing that
happens here
is carol's confusion when she gets this
message that's from bob
before she gets the message from alice
that causally preceded it
so this is the part that i'm a little
bit uncertain about because i'm teaching
this in a different way than i've i've
taught it before
but i'm going to take a stab at it and
uh and we'll see how we do
the reason i'm teaching it in a
different way is because in the time
since i last taught this class a year
ago i've actually done a lot of thinking
about this problem
because in fact patrick and i have been
thinking about it a lot in our research
so
um so there's a different way that i
want to talk about it
than i did last year and we'll see how
it goes
so recall that we talked about vector
clocks before
and i want to briefly talk about the
vector clocks algorithm again with a
minor twist
and the twist is going to be don't
count message receives
as events
so before we were using vector clocks to
count up events that had occurred on
different processes and keep track of
how many events had occurred on which
processes
and we did that by counting events that
occurred
both the sends and the receives and the
internal events this time we're going to
do it a little differently and we're not
going to count the message receives
because it turns out that we don't have
to for this particular algorithm
so it's going to go like this
um yeah so i'll say it like this when a
process
sends
a message
it increments
its own position
in its vector clock i guess i should
write down the first step that every
process keeps a vector clock
that's the same as before
so every process keeps a vector clock
that's initially all zeros
when a process sends a message it's
going to increment its own position
in its vector clock so whichever entry
in the vector clock belongs to that
process
it's going to increment
and it's going to include
the updated vector clock
with the message
so that's the same as we talked about
before
and then
we're going to say when a process
delivers a message
it updates its vector clock
to the pointwise maximum
of its local vector clock
and the received
vector clock on the message
so that's it let's look at a brief
example of an execution
that uses this protocol
so maybe you've got three processes and
so everybody's going to keep a vector
clock that's initially zero
all right let's say that process one
sends a message
and these are uh these are only going to
be broadcast messages
so i'm going to leave out the self
arrows here but you can kind of pretend
that they're there
so this is a this is an event this is a
message
being sent by process one and so it's
going to increment its own position
and then that one zero zero vector clock
is going to get sent along
like that
along with the regular content of the
message this vector clock is going to
tag along
as metadata with the message metadata is
just kind of additional data that goes
with it
and then you can imagine maybe over here
process three is sending one
so this one would get updated to zero
zero one
and then once again that's going to tag
along
this is the updated vector clocks
algorithm
so we're looking at the vector clocks
algorithm that we had before
and um we're updating it slightly
so i haven't quite gotten to
enforcing causal delivery yet
so the question was are we doing causal
delivery are we doing causal broadcast
well we're not really doing either yet
we're just kind of setting things up
so what happens here well
um process one is going to receive this
message
it's going to have a vector clock
attached of 0
0 1 and it's going to update its vector
clock
and it's going to do that by taking the
point wise maximum of the two
it's a little bit different from before
because before we were counting message
receives as events
so we're not doing that here notice that
we're just taking the pointwise maximum
of the two
and we're not counting the receive as an
event
and likewise over here this one zero
zero is going to come along
this message is going to get here
we'll again take the point-wise maximum
and so on so you can imagine more
messages getting sent here
but um so this is just an example
execution that uses this
updated slightly different vector clocks
protocol
that's really the same as before except
that
there's this twist which is that we're
no longer counting message receives as
events
these are still vector clocks anytime
you use vector clocks because the point
of vector collects is to count events
right
so anytime you use vector clocks an
important question to ask is
what do you want to count as an event so
it turns out that in this case
we're not going to count receives as
events so when we get to the end of this
execution here
the vector clock on an event or on a
process like this like like p1 has one
zero one
um this you can think of this as meaning
it's it's like a count of all the sends
that we know about
from everybody so process one at this
point knows about
one message that it sent and it knows
about one message the press is three
cent
and process three at this point also
knows about one message that process one
sent and one message that it sent
itself that's the way that you interpret
the meaning of vector clocks in this
setting
notice that also um i used the word
delivers here
instead of receives and that's going to
be important because we're about to
use this updated vector clocks algorithm
to talk about how we're going to
implement
causal delivery
so the question that somebody just asked
was
are we talking about causal delivery or
are we talking about causal broadcast so
let me
try to distinguish between the two
so causal delivery is the property that
we care about
causal broadcast is an algorithm that we
are going to be implementing
which enforces causal delivery in the
case where all messages are all
broadcast messages so let me write that
down in case it was a little bit unclear
or vague
so causal delivery is the property we
care about it's a property of executions
so
and causal broadcast
is an algorithm
that gives you causal delivery
in a setting where all messages are
broadcast messages
so you might naturally wonder at this
point how would i get causal delivery if
i'm in a setting
uh where all messages are not broadcast
messages
so that's a damn good question and
my somewhat unsatisfying answer to that
is that we're not going to talk about an
algorithm for that
we're not going to talk about an
algorithm for general causal delivery
because it's more involved and more
annoying
so instead we're just going to talk
about this algorithm for call
for causal broadcast uh and it turns out
that the basic ideas behind a general
causal delivery algorithm
are similar but they're more tedious and
annoying
so for now we're going to stick with
just talking about an algorithm for
causal broadcast
and that it turns out is going to be
good enough to help us
avoid things like this alice bob carroll
situation
because as you can see from looking at
those the picture
those were broadcast messages so
this algorithm for causal broadcast is
going to be good enough to
rule out this kind of anomaly
questions about that
all right so
um let's see
i think with this particular way of
explaining causal broadcast
i think the best way to do it
is the following so
i'll draw a picture of an execution
that that does the bad thing that we
don't want
and let me try putting some vector
clocks
on these events
so that we can see how we can use vector
clocks
to implement causal broadcast
so once again everybody's going to start
with zeros
process one will send this message
vector clock gets sent along
so recall from the algorithm that we
just saw
we said when a process delivers a
message it's going to update its vector
clock to the pointwise maximum
of its local vector clock and the
received vector clock
on the message so coming back to this
picture
let's look at what would happen if we
just delivered everything
right away as soon as we received it
well then process two would get this
message
and it would update its vector clock
because it's taking
the pointwise maximum of one zero zero
and its local vector clock which is just
zero zero zero so it's going to update
to
one zero zero
the next thing that it does is it sends
a message
so it's gonna
increment its own position because it's
sending a message
that message will get here and i didn't
actually write the vector clocks on the
messages but i could
so just to make it very explicit
this message from p2 gets to p1 it's
going to look at these two
and it's going to take the pointwise
maximum so the maximum of one and one is
one
the maximum of zero and one is one
maximum of zero and zero is zero
here the maximum of one one zero and
zero zero
zero is one one zero
and here
the maximum of one one zero and one zero
zero is one one
zero so we know
right that this event
was where the badness happened
right because
we know that this event over here
on process one causally preceded the
send
of this event here on process two we
know that because we know about
causality and we know about happens
before so we know that this one happened
before this one
and yet um if we're calling this message
message one and this one message two
and yet message two is arriving first on
process three
so here's my question for you
you know that this is what you wanna
prevent right you know that you want to
prevent
message two from getting delivered
before message one
over here on process three this is the
bad thing
how can you use the vector clock value
that's coming on message two
to tell you what you're allowed to
deliver and what you should not deliver
right away
so there's another question in chat
which is i'm confused between delivered
and received
are we assuming that when a message is
received it's considered to be delivered
so in this picture i drew here
i haven't showed you how to do
how to enforce causal broadcast yet so
in this picture here we're just
delivering we're not giving any
attention to causal delivery we're just
delivering everything in this
in this picture as soon as we get it but
that's clearly not the way to go
right it's clearly not the right thing
to do to just deliver everything as soon
as you get it
because if you did that then you could
end up in a situation like this
where process 3 is delivering this
message
too soon
so what we would like to do is
somehow be able to make use of this
handy
vector clock information that's tagging
along on these messages
to tell us when is a message okay to
deliver
and when should it be kept in reserve
and in particular what i would like to
make happen is
instead of delivering this message when
it gets right here to process three
i would like to queue it up
and sort of
delay delivering of it until after this
other one has been delivered
so how would we accomplish that
and that's kind of the key question that
we have to figure out in order to
implement causal broadcast
how are we going to choose
whether to deliver a message
so there's starting to be some good
suggestions in chat here
one of them is should we only deliver a
message that has a vector clock
less than or equal to the most recently
received one
um yeah so another
one has to do with if you get this and i
like this suggestion a lot if you get
this message that has a one one zero on
it well what does that mean
well the message came from p2
and this one right here is an indication
that
p2 has sent one message but look your
vector clock at this point is only zero
zero zero
you don't know about any messages from
anybody at this point
so this one one zero comes along well
what does that mean it means that p2
knew about this other message on process
one
and that's what that first one means so
that should be a big fat
warning to you when you receive a
message with a vector clock of one one
zero
the sender knew about something that you
didn't know about
so that seems like a problem right
whereas this one here
this one came from p1 it had a clock of
one zero zero
well that seems okay right there's the
one which
represents the fact that p1 sent a
message right
but it gets here and that should be fine
right like that's
the only thing that's different about
this vector clock from yours
is the knowledge of that sent message
that is in fact this message itself
so that one seems okay and this one
doesn't seem okay
so what we want to do
for causal broadcast
we want to
define a condition
i'll call it the deliverability
condition
whoops deliver a bill etty
condition that tells us
if a received message
is or is not okay to deliver
and this this deliverability condition
is going to use the vector clock on the
message
it's
so without further ado
here's the deliverability condition that
we want
we're going to say that a message
m is deliverable
at a process p
if
there's going to be two parts of this so
first we want to look
at the vector clock
of the message
in the pers in the particular sender's
position
so i'm going to say so if this is the
vector clock of the message
i'm going and recall a vector clock of
of message m is just
a vector of integers i'm going to index
into it at a particular k
that's going to give us a particular
position in the vector
that has to be
equal to
the vector clock
of p that's the process that's receiving
the message
at position k plus one
so in other words the vector clock
that's coming in on the message
in the receiver's position it's got to
be one bigger
than whatever the receiver has in that
position
and this is um
[Music]
um and this then k here is the sender's
position
so this is if k is the sender and then
the other part
of this definition is
for every other k
so for every other index into the vector
clock
that's not the position of the sender
the entry on that position and message
has to be less than or equal to
the vector clock on the process so just
a little explanation of the notation
here
um v c m
is
the vc coming in on the message
and vcp
is the vc on the process
so two pieces to this definition
and together they make up the
deliverability condition i should say
here
um so k here is going to range over all
the entries
so n is the number of entries in the
vector clock k
is going to be an index into that vector
clock
so that's going to be the deliverability
condition so
putting that together
with what we talked about a little while
ago with our updated
vector clock algorithm we're going to
use this
as a way to decide whether to deliver a
message that we've gotten
and let's see how well that works
by looking at an example
so i'll move this here
so we can still see our definition of
deliverability
and
let's go back to our classic alice bob
carroll example
once again
so alice is going to send
bob is going to send in response to that
whoops one one zero here's carol
carol has received a message and the
little mail clerk that's hanging out
here on carol
has to decide whether or not to deliver
that message
how is the mail clerk going to make that
decision
well they're going to check the
deliverability condition
so is the message deliverable well
it's got a vc of one one zero
and carol's current vector clock is zero
zero zero
carol will look at this or carol's mail
clerk will look at this and say
okay well in the center's position which
is bob's position right here
it's one bigger than mine so that's good
right condition one checks out
so in the sender's position the vector
clock on the message
is one bigger than whatever my current
vector clock is
so the first condition checks out but
then the other condition
you see this so this says in every
other position the vector clock on the
message has to be less than or equal to
whatever my vector clock is on my
process
and that is where we have a problem
because this one right here
violates that
so carol's mail clerk will say no
i will not deliver this message right
now
instead it's going to be stuck into a
queue for delivery later
and we can we sometimes call that the
delay queue
so this one goes into the delay queue
a little while later alice's message
shows up at carol it has a vc of one one
zero or sorry one zero zero
carol looks at it
does it uh does it observe this first
property of deliverability well
the entry in the center's position is
one bigger than
carroll's current entry of zero zero
zero so that checks out
and then the other property is that in
every other position it has to be
less than or equal to what carol has and
indeed it is it's got zeros in those
positions and so does carol
so it's good to go there and then
so carol can deliver that one
now carol's local vector clock is
updated right so this becomes a one
so now this message that got delayed
earlier
now the mail clerk can go back and say
oh well now my process vector clock has
changed
right now my process clock is one zero
zero
the um the vector clock on the on on
this original
message from bob was one one zero does
it meet the criteria well
um
i've got a clock of one zero zero indeed
this one is one bigger from mine in the
center's position
and in every other position it's less
than or equal to mine
so this message um from bob can now be
delivered
and so this no turns into a yes
and so we're in good shape so what just
happened here
is that carol got a message from bob
and her mail clerk decided to delay it
until this other one had been delivered
and then finally it was okay to deliver
the um
the message um from bob after the one
from alice
that's causal delivery
let's walk through another example just
to make sure that we understand
so here's a fun one
so let's say that we have
lindsey
abhai and patrick
so i'm really bad about keeping track of
my belongings
and i lose them all the time so
let's say that i lost my phone
actually let's say that i lost my my
keys because if i lost my phone i
wouldn't have a way to send a text to
abhayan patrick let's say that i lost my
keys
so i send a message to them
i lost my keys
and let's say that it goes like this
so they get the message
and let's say they so okay so let's say
abba gets this message from me
i lost my keys and this is the first
event
on me so
i'm going to increment the vector clock
right and so that
updated vector clock is going to go
along on the message
sure sorry about that
hopefully it's clear now i don't know
why it comes out of focus every now and
then
okay so um
is this message safe to deliver when it
gets to abhay
right here under causal delivery is it
safe to deliver
what do you think
yup so we're going to go ahead and
deliver it
up his vector clock gets updated
his process clock gets updated to one
zero zero what about it patrick is it
safe to deliver for
uh for him too
yeah that should be fine also
okay so then
let's say that i find my keys
and i'm really happy
so i then send another announcement
saying that i found my case and this
one's gonna have a vc
of two zero zero
because it's the second event uh the
second message that i've sent
and i don't know about any sense from
anyone else
so it's going to have a vector clock of
two zero zero the message gets here
is this one okay to deliver
yeah this one should be fine
and if you think back to the delivery
conditions that we talked about a second
ago
why is it fine well it's fine because
it's
one bigger than ave's current vector
clock in the one
in in the in the center's position so
it's two instead of one so it's one
bigger there
and it's less than or equal in every
other position so if you think back to
that deliverability condition we talked
about earlier
everything checks out and we're good to
go we can deliver the message
but then let's say that oppai sends a
friendly response
to me and patrick so let's say that he
says
yay
well this is a message send so it's got
to be counted
in the vector clock so his own position
is going to get incremented
likewise over here
i received the message from mobi should
i deliver this message
i should why should i deliver it because
it's one bigger than my current vector
clock of zero zero zero
or sorry my vector clock is two zero
zero this one's one bigger in the
center's position which is this position
right here
and it's less than or equal to me and
every other position so this one's good
to go
but what happens over here
um patrick gets the message of yay
if we were not doing causal delivery
then this would be kind of a rude
message to send
right because the last thing that
patrick heard was that i lost my keys
and then abba is saying yay so that's
not really a nice thing
to say in response to somebody losing
their keys thankfully
causal delivery prevents us from being
so rude because
when we compare that vector clock of 210
with our own clock
we see that it's bigger than us in the
center's position
or or by one um
which is this the second position here
so it's bigger by one in that position
but it doesn't observe the other
property that we want which is that it's
less than or equal to us in every other
position
so this one should not get delivered and
instead it's going to get queued
2 0 0 comes along is this one safe to
deliver
it is so this one's good
we update to 2 0 0 for our vector clock
and now finally the queued message
can be delivered and now that patrick
knows that i lost my keys and i found
them
now finally we get the message for
mobile which says yay
and so now the message can be delivered
down here and now our
our queue is empty so there was a
fantastic question um
in chat a second ago which was how big
do you make the queue
that's a really good question right if
messages
are piling up let's say that abba sent a
bunch of messages
that for whatever reason arrived at me
um
or arrived at patrick rather uh
before mine so if he had sent a whole
bunch of messages here
that were right here how big does that
cue have to be
well we hope that it's not
actually so many messages that it's
going to
uh overflow the queue right um and so
patrick and i actually implemented
a cue like this for
um for a project that we worked on
recently
and there's a lot of factors to consider
here like how far
apart are all of these nodes and how
often do you anticipate there being
message delays
but yeah unbounded message queues can be
a problem in distributed systems ask any
erlang programmer about that
but um we hope that for the most part
these cues won't get
too large
so there's a couple of interesting
things to think about here
no one is like how do you guarantee that
you never deliver a message too soon
well i've just sketched out an algorithm
for that guarantee
but another thing to think about is how
do you make sure
that messages don't get stuck in the
delay queue forever
so that would be what's called a
liveness guarantee
and that one's actually a little bit
harder to prove
so one way to implement something
that you know this is kind of like when
we were talking about fifo before when
we talked about fifo delivery
if i just dropped every received message
on the floor
then it wouldn't be violating fifo
because
i wouldn't be delivering any messages in
the wrong order i would not be
delivering them at all
but that wouldn't give us what we really
wanted which is which would be to
deliver the messages but deliver them in
a given order
so that's what's called a liveness
property to make sure that messages do
eventually get delivered and we're going
to be talking about this notion of
aliveness property
much more a lot later uh in the course
all right
i think that's about time for a break
because we've been talking quite a lot
uh so let's do our 10 minute break now
and
i'll switch over to our quiz question
and let's resume
at 4 eight
google says i've been signed out just a
moment i'll post a link into this
question in just a second
okay i think i've been signed in again
sorry about that
okay
so here's the link to the quiz in zulip
and i'll see you in 10 minutes at 4 38.
i
you
two minute warning
all right it's 4 38 so welcome back
so i mentioned before that our schedule
was ambitious when i said we were going
to talk about the chandi langport
snapshot algorithm
today and indeed i don't think that
we're going to have time to talk about
it
in the 17 minutes or so that we have
left
at least not in great detail but we can
talk about it a little bit
so let's step let's set the stage
and then we'll come back next time and
talk about it in a lot more detail
uh so
snapshots of distributed systems
so one thing that i've mentioned
a couple of times in this class is that
in a distributed system processes have
state
right and that state can be thought of
as you know the collection of the events
that have occurred on that process right
so if you've got a bunch of different
processes here maybe they each have some
events and
you know maybe there's some message
sends and some message
receives and possibly some internal
events
so everybody's got their own state
individual processes have states and we
can we can say that the state of a
process amounts to all the events that
happened on it
up to a particular point
but how do i want to how can i talk
about the global state of this system
what if i want to talk about the state
of all of these processes at once
well that's a little bit harder to do
so if we had a globally synchronized
time of day clock
then we could say okay everybody take a
snapshot of yourself
at 3 20 pm but
my 3 20 p.m is not necessarily the same
as your 3 20 p.m and note that i'm not
talking about time zones here
i'm just talking about different clock
synchronization so you can assume that
everybody's using say
utc but even so
my notion of a particular time is not
going to be exactly the same as yours
so you could get this kind of badness
right where if you have two processes
and you know maybe process one has had
some events
and then this is 3 20 p.m
on process one and then maybe process
two has some events and let's say this
one here is a
receive of a message that was sent after
from process one at least as far as
process one thinks of 320
but maybe right here is where 320 is
according to process 2. well if i were
trying to snapshot state by saying
everybody take a snapshot of yourself
when you think it's 320
then process 2's snapshot would look
like this
but process one snapshot would look like
this
so process two would would say oh well i
received this message
process one would be thinking what there
was no message
not in my snapshot so according to
process one this thing that process two
claimed happen
never happened so we can't do that
we cannot use time of day clocks to take
snapshots
clearly they're not going to be useful
to us in that setting so what we need
is an algorithm that will allow us to
take a global snapshot of a distributed
system
that makes sense but without using these
kinds of time of day hacks so
it's a little bit tricky and there are
some ways to take a snapshot that makes
sense
in other ways that really don't but
here's a property that i would really
like to have be true
so if you have two events a and b
where a happens before b
and b is in the snapshot
then what what do you think should be
true
that's right a should be in the snapshot
too
so notice this use of the happens before
relation yet again
it's another place where the happens
before relation is going to be useful to
us
so how do we accomplish that how do we
design an algorithm that will let us
take a snapshot
of a distributed system that will
ensure that this property is true where
if you have an event that's in a
snapshot
any event that happened before it is
going to be in the snapshot as well
so we're going to be talking about a
classic algorithm
for doing that for taking a snapshot of
a distributed system
and in fact this is the pioneering
algorithm
for taking snapshots of distributed
systems it's called the chandy
lanport algorithm
so it's called the chandylan port
algorithm because it's named after two
famous distributed systems people one of
them of course is leslie lamport who
we've already talked about a couple of
times
he's the namesake of lanport diagrams
and lanport clocks
so obviously he's made a lot of
important contributions distributed
systems
the other person is money chandy so
so manichandi and leslie lamport whoops
developed this algorithm i think this
was published in 1985
but you can fact check me on that it was
something some time around then
so because we don't have a whole lot of
time left today i'm not going to be able
to go into all the details of the
algorithm
but i want to just give you a little bit
of a flavor of it
so anytime you talk about the chandy
lane port algorithm you have to tell the
origin story
so supposedly um
chandy and lanport were hanging out one
night um
over dinner and they were talking about
this problem how
how would you compute a distributed
global snapshot
and so apparently they'd had like a
little too much wine
and they couldn't really figure out how
to solve the problem right then
and supposedly according to lamport
he came up with the solution in the
shower the next morning and he
was so happy then he hurried over to
chandi's office
to talk about it with him and shandy was
already in the office and waiting for
him there with the same solution so
apparently they both
figured this out independently
and so that's why we give them both
credit
so let's talk about what the algorithm
does
and again we won't have time for all the
details today but let's
let's talk about it at a high level uh
so before we start
we're going to need a piece of
terminology which is new
and that's the notion of what's called a
channel
so a channel can be thought of as
the connection from one process to
another
so if you have processes
p1 and p2 uh sending and receiving
messages
then we have two channels in this case
there's the channel from p1 to p2
and there's a channel from uh from p2 to
p1
so channels are one way they go from one
process to the other
so it's like a one-way road
so in particular like if this were event
a and this were event b
and a were ascend and b where it
received
uh then this message we can call it m1
traveled through the channel from
process one to process two
and the naming convention we're going to
use for channels is going to be
the letter c uh subscripted with
uh two numbers
which are id
of the sender
and the id of the receiver
so c12 is going to be the name of the
channel from process 1 to process 2.
and likewise c21 is going to be the
channel from
p2 to p1
so maybe i have another message here
and let's say that it's in flight from
process two to process one
so we can think of that message while
it's in flight as being currently in the
channel
so in this particular picture the
channel c21 has one message in it
and the channel c12 is currently empty
because
there was a message that went through it
earlier but there isn't right now
we're going to assume that messages go
through channels
in fifo order
so channels are going to act like fifo
cues
so if process two were to send another
message
then the behavior is going to be that
if we can think of c21 as being a
sequence of messages
there's no passing on this one way road
so
process one has to get message two
before it gets message three
so the notion of fifo delivery that we
talked about before that's kind of baked
in here to this concept of channels
all right we have confirmation in the
chat that uh
the chandelier algorithm is indeed from
1985 so i got it right thank you
okay
i don't think that we have time in the
five minutes remaining sadly to really
talk about how the chandelier import
algorithm works
uh so let me pause right here to see if
there's questions about
anything that i've discussed so far and
then we'll have to save everything for
the next time
okay no questions
then i think we're going to conclude by
just drawing a few pictures that will
hopefully give you an intuition
for how the algorithm works and then
next time we'll talk about all the gory
details
so we want the snapshots that we take to
make sense
uh so let me draw a couple examples of
snapshots and you can tell me whether or
not you think they make sense
so let's say that we have a couple of
processes here
and a couple of messages
so a snapshot is going to consist of the
state
of each process
so here's an example of a snapshot
process 2 is going to snapshot its state
like this
process one it's going to snap shut its
state like this
do you think this is a good snapshot
no yeah we don't want this one why is it
bad well
there's this event a up here and it
happened before b
right it also happened before d and yet
b
and d are in the snapshot and c as well
c also a also happened before c
transitively but a is not being included
okay well here's a different snapshot of
the same execution
is this one a good snapshot
yeah that's right so c and d aren't
included
but is it a good snapshot according to
the criterion that we had before
yeah it turns out it is this one is
perfectly good
it might not be
everything that we ever dreamed of
but it doesn't violate the property that
we talked about before
where if an event is in the snapshot so
is everything that happened before it
so this one is actually perfectly okay
according to to our definition of what
makes a good snapshot
and then this would also be okay
so this is another perfectly legal
snapshot
and then a snapshot that had all the
events too would would be fine
so a snapshot may not tell you
everything that you ever wanted to know
but you want it to be a consistent
snapshot in other words
you don't want to have any weird stuff
like this where you have an event
that was in the snapshot but then that
event
happened before some other event that
was left out because it can be very
mysterious looking at these sorts of
snapshots later on to try to understand
what's going on
and the reason why is because one thing
that we might want to use these
snapshots for is trying to debug a
problem so
when we go and try to debug maybe we're
trying to figure
maybe maybe this message never should
have been sent maybe c
never should have been sent over here or
or this call it m1
maybe m1 never should have been sent
here and um
we're trying to figure out why maybe
somehow that message was sent because of
a
well if we're going to have any shot at
debugging it
then a had better be included in the
snapshot that we're inspecting so that's
why
we care about our snapshots being
consistent so next time we'll talk about
the algorithm
for taking these consistent snapshots
and i will see you next time take care
you